[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
addressing a question asked in the
comment section
which was how did harry return from
limbo
in case you had forgotten harry actually
ends up dying at one point
after an encounter with voldemort in the
forbidden forest
harry looked back into the red eyes and
wanted it to happen now
quickly while he could still stand
before he lost control
before he betrayed fear he saw the mouth
move and a flash of green light
and everything was gone and the next
thing we know harry's beginning to
regain consciousness
only he's not in the forbidden forest
anymore in fact
entirely disoriented he didn't know
where he was
he lay in a bright mist though it was
not like mist he had ever
experienced before his surroundings were
not hidden by cloudy vapor
rather the cloudy vapor had not yet
formed into surroundings
the floor on which he lay seemed to be
white neither warm nor cold
but simply there a flat blanked
something
on which to be his environment was
completely surreal
and harry had lost all of his bearings
in fact
he had no idea if what he was
experiencing was real
or just a figment of his imagination
tell me one last thing
is this real or has this been happening
inside my head
to which dumbledore replies of course it
is happening inside your head harry
but why on earth should that mean that
it is not real
harry after a minor adjustment to his
surroundings also noticed that the mist
had begun to form
in the shape of king's cross station
where he first departed to hogwarts
so many years ago but harry wasn't truly
at king's cross
so where was he as it turns out he was
in limbo
limbo in many religions can be described
as the border place between heaven and
hell
where souls go before moving on to the
afterlife
it's never explicitly described in the
book whether or not
all souls in the harry potter universe
go through this point in limbo
however i'm of the impression that harry
went there due to his unique
circumstances
and tethering to voldemort i certainly
think that it's a bit more exclusive
than
everyone and limbo would ordinarily be
the place
that people would go before they're
choosing to move on to the afterlife
or choosing to remain in the world of
living as a ghost
here's why harry's situation in limbo
was more complicated
he wasn't actually dead during harry's
talk with dumbledore
dumbledore explains that harry is in
fact very much alive
for his soul was still entirely intact
whole
so despite being in limbo harry was
alive which meant that
yes he could choose to go on to the
afterlife
but he also had the much better option
of returning to the land of living
as a whole person harry could board the
train
and go on or he could just return to
where he came from
harry chose the latter okay but now you
might be wondering
how how was harry still alive harry
never dies because his mother's
sacrifice
the same magic that has protected him
for all his life
is still alive in lord voldemort's veins
he took my blood
said harry precisely said dumbledore
he took your blood and rebuilt his
living body with it your blood in his
veins harry
lily's protection inside both of you he
tethered you to life while he lives
so in essence harry was able to come
back because voldemort
had used harry's blood to regenerate
when voldemort cast the killing curse on
harry
it didn't work properly it only
destroyed the horcrux inside harry
and that's it for this video did you
ever wonder how and
why harry was able to return comment
down below
until next time you're wizard harry
you